joining me now delighted he's with us
how's minority leader Kevin McCarthy
leader McCarthy great to see you tonight
now the issue uh with Washington in a
lame duck session is what in your
estimation they try to do exactly what
you said when I listen to this this
sounded like what I was saying to the
president during my meeting last week
the vice president actually brought up
she says what can we do about the
dreamers I said nothing you got to
secure the Border I invited the
president down to go the border with me
and he made the mistake and asked me
what would I do I rolled through
everything because I was just there in
El Paso you bring that number up of 70
000 in one overpass in seven weeks 70
000 people have come across one overpass
we don't control our border anymore the
cartels do you can see tracers coming to
our National Guard you can see a lady
who didn't pay I don't care though let's
let's just they don't use everybody they
do not care about this no but they're
destroying our nation because what is
happening down there you already have
three million across if they lift title
42 just in the next two years while he's
in office 13 million more people they
project you won't be a speaker for long
if they do that I'm sorry no but if you
can't allow it I mean I told the
president I was very clear from the very
beginning we if he wants the ndaa I told
him you've got to lift the vaccine
mandate on our on our military men and
women why they're not meeting the
recruitment goals right now because of
this they're people are leaving and why
should they be voting on any of this why
shouldn't they do continuing resolution
short-term spending well that's
different that's Appropriations that's
exactly is the extra money they want for
the Pentacles Democrats to vote on this
I want this to go in law because but
this is what's going to happen when
we're in power or single subject people
aren't going to be able to throw in pot
funding in the others right now that's
not in we're trying to hold all that out
in the process why are you talking about
the military about this because I mean I
I I mean he's so smart in so many ways
did all the great judges but this
Omnibus thing takes away your power for
10 months you will have no effect on
these critical issues zero we're 28 days
away from Republicans having the gavel
we would be stronger in every
negotiation so any Republican that's out
there trying to work with them is wrong
with the hand does that include
McConnell yes why would you want to work
on anything if we have the gavel inside
Congress you just we have a stronger yes
wait till we're in charge I told the
president if we don't have the lifting
of the vaccine
I'll do it and I'll do it in January
there's no I told the Secretary of
Defense he had him call me just Sunday
night but don't do they kind of know
people are moving away from the vaccine
mandates anyway is that kind of a I know
they said they don't but because this
all be posturing and we're all kind of
playing the movie theater here they're
not and we want to put it in law so they
can think about if we win it here where
we can push it everywhere else all right
speaking of what that meeting with Biden
was like here's the story the president
has been telling they say they were
telling me that what we could do and
what they were going to do and I said
yeah Biden recall demonstrating that he
responded to McCarthy by lifting up his
pen and showing it to the room they said
what are you doing a pen a veto he said
Congressman what's your side of that
story he didn't say that he lifted up
his pen because I said he was playing
politics and they lifted up his pen and
shot let's put it down and shut up and
then he came back to talk to me
afterwards and say I wasn't trying to be
political Kevin I said you know what you
need to do you need to go the border
with me because right now the fentanyl
that is killing our children were the
the
the millions who are coming across the
people who Being Human Trafficking I
said you don't understand what's
happening they do understand I requested
we put the Navy Seals in with the Border
agent they have the Border agents being
process agents instead of being on the
job the big the big um question I've
been getting pinged by this all day is
this RNC leadership question because a
lot of Republicans are worried because
they think you know glad they won the
house and a couple more seats look like
they're picked up we're gonna talk to
John Duarte in a minute
who do you think now
should take over as RNC chair we like
Ronald McDonald a lot personally I think
she's she's a great person I like her
heart meet Dylan is a young female
California uh obviously indian-american
look I like Army she's my national
commitment I think she does a tremendous
job but I think Rhonda did a tremendous
job too look would you look across the
country
every Republican entity lost us at the
house I've been leader for four years
we've won every single time what about
early voting for those Senate races she
could have helped on that right I've
watched her down doing it the one thing
I see happening the Senate lost the the
governor's loss the president lost but
the house has won in both Cycles even
we've picked up in California we picked
up in Oregon we picked up in New York
we we want five seats that Biden won by
more than 10 points we beat the D Triple
C chair that hasn't happened in 42 years
I think the quality of the candidate
matters we could have done better in
Pennsylvania with a better governor
candidate there it cost us a thing but
look I saw the resources day I saw the
engagement in there and the RNC is a
small group of individuals the committee
men and committee women I think it
should be decentralized I mean she threw
out that idea on the show last week that
it should be why based in Washington
send it to the to the Heartland to the
importance of States breaking it out
with everywhere we should decentralize
we got to get out of Washington I looked
that from a government point of view why
is the Department of energy in
Washington what do they produce and why
is the department
get it out to the American public let
them understand well we continue to make
progress in California a California's
just got to turn at some point we won in
Congress every single second we won in
La we want we won three seats that Biden
had carried by more than 10 points so
you know what we proved in the house we
can win in every single place the
quality candidate matters having the
resources and having the right so your
message again Tom Tillis McConnell hold
off
in days can't you wait because what will
happen then is you'll get a Republican
bill out of the house you'll be in a
stronger negotiation position and we'll
be cutting instead of adding more money
it's great to see you thank you so much
thank you coming in tonight really
appreciate it thank you leader McCarthy
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else